في هذه الاثناء نقلت شبكه سي ان عن وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه انه تمت الموافقه على
شحن الدفعه الاولى من دبابات ابرامز
الامريكيه الى اوكرانيا خلال نهايه
الاسبوع الماضي وقال البنتاجون انه من
المتوقع ان تصل دبابات الامريكيه الى
اوكرانيا مطلع الخريف المقبل
معنا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجيه اهلا بكم معناه
السيد حنا اذا ما الذي تعنيه هذه الموافقه
الامريكيه التي تاتي الان بشحن دبابات
ابرامز الى اوكرانيا لماذا الان وما الذي
ستضيفه هذه الدبابات للقوات الاوكرانيه
اولا هذا وعد قديم يتحقق اليوم بدء نقلها
يجب ان نسال ما هي التجهيزات التقنيه
والتكنولوجيه الحديثه المتواجده في هذه
الدبابات اثنين نقلها العدد مهم العدد
تقريبا مهم ثلاثه التدريبات وبالتالي
عمليه اشراكها مع القيادات مع القوات
المختلفه مع الالويه التي اصبحت على ارض
الميدان وهذا الامر اعتقد يتطلب وقت اساسي
مهمه لماذا مهمه مهمه لانها للخرق يعني هي
تشكل قوه صدم
الدبابه بالاضافه الى القوه الناريه ولكن
بالتالي نلاحظ حاليا سهام ان الهجوم
العكسي الاوكراني متعثر الى حد ما هذا امر
يعتبر اضافه نوعيه غير هذه الدبابات من
هذا الواقع
لن تغير بالمعنى التغيير الجذري التغيير
الجذري ينقصه منظومه اكبر بالحد الادنى
تتمتع بحمايه جويه وهدم ما تفتقده القوات
الاوكرانيه على طول خط التماس ستكون اضافه
نوعيه
الوفاء بالوعد الامريكي ولكن هذا الامر قد
يكون لمرحله لاحقه ولن يكون التغيير اساسي
واني في هذا الوقت سهام
سياده العميد اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن
التطورات الاخيره يلحظ الاتهامات
المتبادله باستهداف مناطق مدنيه الجانب
الروسي يتهم اوكرانيا في ذات الاطار كما
شاهدنا مع مازن ابراهيم اوكرانيه للجانب
الروسي هل هو بالضروره
يعني يعكس امرا ما فيما يتعلق باستراتيجيه
الهجوم والهجوم المضاد لهما
عبد السلام
روسيه تريد افشال الهجوم تريد ان تجعل من
اوكرانيا بلد غير قابل للعيش ومن هنا
الاستهداف لكل البنى التحتيه مياه كهرباء
صناعه وحتى المدن على سبيل المثال
المدينه التي تحدث عنها مازن هذه مدينه
مهمه جدا لماذا يعني اذا اخذنا خط التماس
900 كم من خركاب الى زفروجيا هذه المدينه
تقع داخل المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
اوكرانيا وهي عقدت طرق تذهب باتجاه مخموت
تذهب باتجاه اوغلادار تذهب باتجاه سيلكا
نوفو سيلكا تجلب باتجاه اوريكيف وكانها
المحور الاساسي وعبطت الطرق وحتى
السكك الحديد لنقل اللوجستيه الى الخط
الامامي لخط التماس من هنا استهداف هذه
المنطقه لانها اصبحت مهمه من كافه الاصعده
وبتزامن مع ذلك التصعيد ايضا متواصل في
البحر الاسود زيليسكي قال ان روسيا ستصبح
قريبا بلا سفن اذا تواصل الهجوم الروسيه
على بلاده مما الات هذا التصعيد في
اعتقادك الى اين يمكن ان يصل
للبحر الاسود ديناميكيه مختلفه سهام هناك
مسيرات بسيطه قليله الكلفه تستهدف
السفن والحاء الناقلات النفط المدنيه وحتى
العسكريه وهذا امر يضع قيود مهمه وصعبه
على
روسيا وكانه المعامله بالمثل اذا لم نقل
نستطيع تصدير القمح فانتم ايضا لن
تستطيعوا تصدير ان كان النفط وهام من هنا
استهداف ناقله ناقله النفط مؤخرا او حتى
السفن العسكريه بين سوتشي وبين قرش
سهامناكا سته مرافق روسيه يمكن استهدافها
ولكن التكرار بالاستهداف هذا يعني ان
لاوكرانيا القدره والوسائل وانها اصبحت
استراتيجيه وتكتيك جديد شكرا لك العميد
الياس حنا الخبير العسكري الاستراتيجي كان
معنا من بيروت